have you found a distributor for along
the roadside the film was distributed in
former Yugoslavia and went theatrical
and I was limited release because we
opened the same day as Lincoln lemaise
more those bills are coming out at the
same time as ours but i guess it the
reached expectations this which was
super long but you know that's that as
far as the rest of the world we just you
know we just had a first screening here
my won best picture at at la
international filmmaker showcase film
festival and we're just starting to
exploit that idea of distribution and
hopefully the rest of the festivals
coming up this year both Europe and us
will open up more opportunities or
possibilities and we're definitely open
to explore going back to the first
distribution deal overseas how did that
come about did you initiate it did they
contact you you will laugh at this I met
my distributor checking him in at the
front desk of the hotel that worked like
we see was there for the american film
market which happens in november each
year so i checked him in and you know I
turned the screen I said look I'm
working on a script and he's like hey I
got good luck with that and then years
went by and then you know I was like I
made that film and then you know then
was I hanging out now where we developed
a relationship and he was willing to see
the film and it's one of those things
you know as far as distribution it's
that's what I really like that's right
he hits you and you will you understand
like how much of a business this whole
thing is and that's when you know
everything's reduced to its market value
and kind of like a we had with tribution
Serbia because one of the actors in the
film is the biggest survey an actor so
of course you can package that and sell
it and they put us on great talk shows
and we had press coverage and all that
get fraction that publicity here it'll
be fun
you know but that's that's that so the
ship uteri gas has to find the angle you
know how in home can they sell this to
and our film will look that both I'm
you've shown packed the house and people
out there with great reviews and there's
definitely people who would enjoy this
film and I think there's really big
number of people globally but the
question is how will how do we like to
know this film exists and even stronger
or more difficult questions how do you
get them to do something about it you
know honey Hollywood's greater that you
know you get in the car you drive
theater you buy at the ucf film you come
out incentives the biggest crap I ever
seen but how would made you do all these
things so you can then come out and say
whatever you want it's really getting
people move them you know to actually
want to go see it wanna buy it purchase
it and do something about it I think
that's really whoever handles that game
and knows how to do that that's their
handling things those people moving yeah
yeah yeah it's how you move the mass
like we have a one youtubers danny is
great following in Serbia I was waiting
clubbing there after after while we were
there and so much like it's one of those
things like people recognizing people
hug and take pictures with him and I
like to time the movies in theaters he's
like okay and then he does and they're
like really when you know and then you
realize there's you know how what do you
do to let people know do you film exists
it's available and how do you get them
excited to see it it's that area is
something that it's that's the real game
yeah I so don't want to play it but you
have to write going back to the
distribution deals what are some of the
things that you
to have a place when you you know said
you're entertaining offers and you've
already been down this road before what
can you tell others who haven't gone
through this yet that they need to know
oh I'm pretty green at it I know that
you know all this communication you know
and I understand the film open with a
bunch of big Hollywood Oscar winners but
you know you move it goes in theaters
and it sounds great but find out what
are the times you know like if it plays
at three-thirty p.m. on a monday and
that's all you get it doesn't really
sound great you know as much as 7pm or a
PM it on friday or saturday so it's it's
this whole you know universe that i
never you know gave a thought and then
Elvis on your like okay I'm so this you
know there's people salaries are here
and you know there is this dysfunctions
it's like the product has to be
distributed I remember one of the guys
wanted to option my strip the one which
made into a film but the contract said
you know no I'm not a direct not Manoli
do not in director yeah don't hang on so
brother and I respectfully decline that
offer but I remember talking to the
person he'll kept referring to our
project is product and that kept kissing
yeah I was like well here's the thing
we'll make this product I don't know who
is he calling a product you know cuz I
always I keep thinking about shelves and
supermarkets your set product and then
you think oh wait a minute it doesn't up
our shelves and it's kind of scary and
it's one of those where a guy with a
different skill set is good to have
nearby who you know doesn't have a
problem with that word and knows exactly
what that means and how to handle it and
know where to go with it
you